our basic freedom is important and we
ought to be left alone and part of that
is freedom to trade with people and
generally that brings good things hey
hey and welcome to the sunday special we
have on as our guest this week John
Stossel you know him from Fox News and
Stossel TV and all of his investigative
reporting we're gonna get into
libertarianism and small government and
regulations and all the rest of it in
just one second but first we're going to
talk about your sleep quality so there's
nobody on the planet like you why would
you buy a generic mattress built for
somebody else helix sleep built a sleep
quiz that takes two minutes to complete
they use the answers to match your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress whether you're a side
sleeper or a hot sleeper whether you
like a plush or firm bed with helix
there's no more guessing and no more
confusion all you have to do is go to
helix sleep calm slash been guest
because I have a guest and take their
two-minute sleepy mm-hmm and they will
match it to a mattress they'll give you
the best sleep of your life for a
couple's helix can't even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've
attained your warranty you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk-free so
what are you waiting for right now helix
is offering up to one hundred and
twenty-five bucks off all mattress
orders again up to one hundred and
twenty-five dollars off at helix sleep
comm slash been guest the mattresses
really are great my wife and I have one
in our room we did the two-minute sleep
quiz it came in the mail we unwrapped it
and inflates right in front you put it
on the bed you're good to go I got one
for my sister for her wedding the hulex
sleep special right now helix sleep calm
slash been guests yet a hundred and
twenty five bucks off your mattress
order again that's helix sleep calm
slash with Ben guests go check it out
right now
helix sleep calm slash up Ben guests all
right John thanks so much for stopping
by I really appreciate it
good to be here so let's start for
people who may not know your background
you started off as a reporter and now
you're seen as both a reporter and sort
of libertarian commentator how did you
come to your political viewpoint and how
did your career progress in this
direction I graduated college and like a
lot of young people I thought capitalism
was ok it brings us some stuff but it's
cruel and unfair and I went to every job
interview I could and the longest free
trip was to Portland Oregon where I
ended up in a TV newsroom
I'd never watched
TV news I got my worst grades in English
I was just taking a year off before
going to grad school and hospital
management I thought if I worked I would
learn to appreciate school more the
opposite happened I appreciated work as
they you don't feel guilty about not
having done all the reading and they pay
you and so I kept working in the
newsroom I never intended to go in the
air I'm a stutterer but they pushed me
and I eventually overcame stuttering and
I became to avoid competing with people
like you who talked fast I just wanted
to cover something that other people
weren't covering so the time all people
did was politics the weather crime
disasters that was news I thought
there's consumer issues out there
psychology medicine companies ripping
people off I'll do that and I did that
and won 19 Emmy Awards bashing business
but I gradually watched the regulation
that I was calling for and often getting
sometimes politicians was that was great
we're gonna pass a law and fix that in
Oregon they created a Department of
Consumer Affairs but then I go back and
do the same story or we'd send a TV set
out to 20 repair shops and 18 would with
a loose part 18 would say oh loose part
no charge to would rip us off I'd go
back and say would you ever do this Oh
No yeah well watch this play the
videotape and it was great television
bashing business but I then so we'd do
it again now there's a Department of
Consumer Affairs the results are the
same most people are honest a few cheats
so what's the Department of Consumer
Affairs doing they have a big dreary
room with a bunch of dreary people at
desks filling out forms now you have to
get a license to be team of your
repairmen
and supposedly that will screen out the
bad guys but it doesn't it just lets in
the ones who are sophisticated enough to
know how to get the license the
immigrant maybe works under beyond the
law in the black market everybody has to
pay a few pennies more to pay for the
lawyers and consumers know better off so
ice
started reading more I didn't love the
conservative press because it looked
like your people wanted to police the
bedroom police the rest of the world and
I didn't like that and I discovered a
reason magazine and that was an epiphany
oh my god these people get it better
than I do and I became a libertarian
let's talk about your brand of
libertarianism so they're a bunch of
kind of different subsets of
libertarianism ranging from gary johnson
who's not really a libertarian to other
folks who seem significantly more
hands-off when it comes to regulations
for example what is your view on when
regulation is important or necessary are
there situations where you think
regulation is is something that needs to
happen yes I think the Constitution had
part of it right we we need rule of law
the worst places to live is the African
country where there's no rule of law and
you're afraid to build a factory because
your neighbor may just steal what you
make or the dictator may take the whole
factory so we need cops and a national
defense stuff that's in the Constitution
I go one further and say we need
government for pollution control rules
some libertarians would say well you
couldn't I can sue you if your smoke
pollutes my air but our legal system is
so cumbersome that's not practical so
thank God for the EPA the air is in the
water have gotten cleaner and beyond
that just about nothing okay so let's
talk about you know the taxation regime
so a lot of folks who are in libertarian
circles are deeply concerned about the
morality of taxes I consider myself
basically a libertarian myself when it
comes to the involvement of government
and I'm very sympathetic to the argument
that taxation is generally theft that
when somebody puts a gun in your face
and then says you need to give me your
money for a purpose that I see fit that
that is a form of theft but what is
taxation not theft is there a moral line
that we can draw because obviously the
government does have to provide certain
services that you talked about if you're
talking about the government providing
safety for your property you need a
police force if you're talking about the
government providing safety from foreign
invasion you need you need Defense
Department is that sort of Taxation
theft and how do you distinguish between
what's tough and what's not I don't
think about it much but I would say no
it's if I have a member
this country and this country needs
national defense which it does and a
local police force and Pollution Control
rules the government has to raise that
money somehow and that's not that that's
just the deal and one of the questions
that that often comes up in this context
is you know so how far does that go so
very often what you hear from folks on
the left is the you didn't build that
thing that you got from Barack Obama or
Elizabeth Warren that because the
government provides roads for example
and rule of law that you didn't build
that the government really built it the
government contributed to your success
how true is that and you know do we need
things like government provided roads
and post offices no we certainly don't
need government post offices rather that
is UPS and FedEx was interesting that
the government could not get it there
overnight and then FedEx did and now
even UPS sometimes does if the private
sector was building roads they we would
have more roads to hit be smoother they
would be better I it's become a role for
government it would be better if they
contracted it out not that people in
government aren't necessarily just as
bright but the incentives are different
you can fire the private road builder if
you don't like what he did if he's great
he makes more money in government
everybody gets paid the same and it's
almost impossible to fire somebody so
even if they're great at the beginning
say when the Peace Corps began following
people looking to help people ten years
later when nobody gets could be promoted
or fired that just eats away it your
wish to do better so one of the
questions folks have about
libertarianism very often this is
usually the key question used to
quote/unquote debunk it is the what do
you do about the folks who fall through
the cracks argument so libertarianism is
based on a certain notion that you have
the capacity to reason and you have the
capacity to make decisions about your
own life that you should bear the
consequences of the decisions that you
make in your own life but what about the
folks who are not capable of making
those decisions children people who are
ill people who are handicapped what do
we do about those folks does government
have a role there or is there something
else that should pick up the slack
something else should pick up the slack
and it depends what you mean but what
should we do is we government or is we
individuals I think we have a moral duty
to help those people both see in
and the mentally ill when government
steps in it crowds out the voluntary
organizations to do that better think
about the depression they come much
poorer America was then twenty five
percent unemployment was way back when
we had less money anyway how many people
start almost no one why because there
were twenty thousand mutual aid
societies around the country all
voluntary many of them racist it was
Koreans helping Koreans or blacks
helping blacks whites helping white but
those groups knew better than government
ever could who needed help and who
needed a kick in the ass and it's just
much more efficient charity now I
realize it's not gonna happen there
we're gonna get rid of all this welfare
we have we've spent seventy one trillion
since it began and I coming out of
Princeton I was going oh yes we know how
to solve poverty my professors said it's
an outrage in this rich country that
some people are poor but then I watched
these programs fail they just teach
people to be dependent and if you look
at the graph I have used this in my
videos of the war on poverty in the
poverty line the war on poverty began
and the poverty rate dropped for seven
years and after that it's going up and
down improvements top because the
government teaches people to be
dependent if you got a man in the house
your check goes down and then most
interesting look at the chart from
before the war on poverty the slope of
the line was about the same Americans
were lifting themselves out of poverty
the war on poverty trillions of dollars
continued progress for five years and
then stopped it so what do you make of
the new kind of left argument with
regard to the countries they admire so
for a long time
for decades the Soviet Union was a place
where they were kind of interested in
the experiment and then for a little
while they're interested in Google
Chavez and they were interested in Cuba
for a while but now the the modern
iteration of the of the socialist
movement is in favor of social
democracies so they like Norway they
like Sweden they like the Nordic
countries this is the one that Bernie
Sanders likes to try it out all the time
what do you make of the argument that
those countries are cohesive the
are functioning well but they have high
standards of living and they also have
massive governmental burdens that are
driven by enormous regulations and tax
rates well first of all they're not
really socialists of the Denmark prime
minister went on TV to say look we're a
market economy we're not socialist
government does not control the means of
production that's the most important
thing Scandinavian countries don't even
have a government minimum wage they do
have a big welfare state and they can
afford that because they have a
homogeneous culture and they have a
fairly free private market to pay for it
on the economic freedom index as they
come out ahead of the united states i
don't know how bernie calls them
socialist do they innovate do they
produce anything is it an accident that
facebook google and all these exciting
wealth-creating companies your podcasts
have come out of Silicon Valley in
California places far away from
Washington DC I don't think so
yeah and that I think is always the big
distinction that folks failed make they
that socialism freezes things in place
and redistributes them and capitalism
generates new and innovative innovative
methods but when it comes to things like
health care where the left really is
putting its heavy focus these days what
they say is okay well fine so we
sacrifice a little bit of innovation but
there's an entire group of people who
have pre-existing conditions and they
don't have a capacity to pay for the
health care that they need
so what's the best system for providing
health care if we're not going to have
some sort of baseline government
provided health care it would be
presumptuous for me to say what the best
system is but what I've learned is that
the more market there is the better and
poor people with a pre-existing
condition are not going to have a market
solution but we have an America
Medicaid for poor people Medicare for us
old people and no hospital emergency
room turns away any poor person we don't
really have a free market system because
the rest of it is paid for not by
individuals but by insurance companies
or government so what really works is
when you go to the doctor and you say
gee doc
really have to cost 200 bucks I'm paying
for this myself
and this is starting to happen with the
health savings accounts company instead
of just having the insurance company pay
for it they give you some money and you
make some of those decisions and doctors
often say really you're paying paying
yourself like now I don't have to wait
two months for the insurance company
okay well $100 and then they don't even
know where to put it because they
haven't had a cash box for so long but
moving toward more consumer driven and
that means high deductibles which nobody
wants to hear about everybody hates that
that's the only answer
and Bernie touch single pay and you're
up you don't pay for anything that's
true in England
forget about Nora England Canada
Australia and it's true you don't pay
but the National Health Service in
England was created the year I was born
and in some cases they still use that
kind of technology because innovations
stops in government you just do you
don't get in trouble if you do what you
did before so I'm kind of going down the
litany of things that folks think
government is necessary for one of the
other one of the other aspects that
folks say the government is necessary
for is the public education system they
suggest that without a public school
system that children will be illiterate
that parents will not put their kids in
schools that poor parents won't be able
to put their kids in places where they
can get educated what do you make of the
argument in favor of public education I
certainly would have believed it when
Horace Mann said this is going to end
crime we just need we have experts we
need to have government run this but
it's the same problem innovation stop
we're still teaching kids the way we
taught them 100 years ago
kids are boys especially are what she
was sitting at the desks and miserable
in school the girl the girls do better
and then you look at success academies
in New York these private charter
schools where the minority kids are
getting top grades there are better ways
to do it and there too the only thing
that works is competition attach the
money to you know in New York they're
spending like
400,000 sick what you could do with that
many up with that money hire three great
teachers where does the money go nobody
knows it's a government monopoly it just
disappears but if you had vouchers or
some system that attaches the money to
the kids schools would compete to get
the kids you to get the good kids they
would shun the slow learners the state
can set up a system where if you are a
special-needs child your voucher is
larger but that kind of competition will
always do better than one-size-fits-all
government so in a second I want to ask
you about why libertarianism hasn't
really become more popular in the United
States at least politically but first we
have to talk about your impending death
so you're gonna die I'm just sorry to
break it to you that's why you need life
insurance life insurance isn't the most
enjoyable thing to talk about because
most people don't like to think about
how they're gonna plotz but actually
having life insurance is a pretty good
feeling it's nice to know that if
anything were to happen to me my family
wouldn't have to start a GoFundMe to
stay afloat policy genius is the easy
way to get life insurance online in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers to find the best policy
for you and when you compare quotes you
save money it is indeed that simple
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage they don't
just make life insurance easy they also
compare disability insurance and auto
insurance and home insurance if you care
about it they can cover it so if you've
been avoiding getting life insurance
because it's kind of tough or confusing
give policy genius a try go to policy
genius com you can get your quotes apply
in minutes getting to the whole thing
right now on your phone just pause this
and go do it policy genius com it's the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance again they make life insurance
incredibly easy and you're not being a
responsible adult if you don't have life
insurance because again I promise you
there's one thing I can guarantee in
your life you're gonna plotz so policy
genius will make it a little bit easier
on your family when you drop dead at the
kitchen table go check it out policy
genius com
okay so perhaps I've never heard pops oh
yeah yeah - David plotz
yeah you know keel over but look at it
so why is libertarianism not more
popular you know it seems to me a you
know again I have heavy libertarian
sympathies and leanings what I've always
said is that I think that the future of
the conservative movement is in a basic
conservative libertarian merger where
conservatives acknowledge the
libertarian
right about government and libertarians
acknowledge that conservatives are right
about the necessity of a social fabric
because it seems to me that one of the
problems I see with in talking to a lot
of libertarians is there's so much focus
on what the government shouldn't do that
there's very little focus on what we
should be as human beings where virtue
comes in where social institutions
necessary there's a sort of negativism
that's directed at sometimes religious
institutions because so many
libertarians feel that religious
institutions are you know ignorance or
promoting ignorance why do you think
there is a crossover between
libertarianism and a certain sort of
secular atheism it seems like in a lot
of areas of the libertarian movement
because most of the argument is
economics that's what it was for me it
was my aha moment that I became a born
again free marketer
I mean clearly with life I see how
religion keeps families together and
brings people together and that that
does wonderful things and religious
people are happier I wish I was as
religious as you are because it brings
people a lot of good stuff in life
why hasn't libertarian libertarianism
become more popular maybe because of
that or my basic answer is I don't know
it's killing me
I've been hot my wife is a leftist well
it was when I married her now she's
moved she would say to the middle but
she still wakes me up with can you
believe that look at this what the New
York Times said what about these people
government has to take care of these
people and I I sort of convinced her
with my argument but the next day it
happens again is in certain people's
women more often in their gut there's
this feeling that government has to take
care of people and that's government's
job and that's where I think that this
is where if the libertarian movement
were to focus a little bit more on the
creation of that social fabric they
would do better just in terms of the
pitch because the the reality is that
human beings exist in terms of identity
both as individuals and also as members
of community libertarians seeing the
government is an overarching threat
which it is they say well you know we
are individuals primarily but that
neglects the fact that we do have this
gut instinct to try and help other
people and we want to get together and
help other people and so
one of the things I have urged
libertarians to do is reach out to
religious communities and make the
libertarian argument for why religious
communities are necessary why you do
need those backstops those charities why
you do need a social fabric built
outside of government because I think
the picture of folks get a flute
harrion's is basically the Libertarian
Party convention which is a bunch of
people talking about legalizing pot
getting rid of seatbelt laws and
everything will be okay but what do you
think the forward-facing pitch for
libertarianism should be because that is
like I saw just this morning I saw a
clip of the 2017 the 2015-2016 primary
debates among the libertarian party
candidates and Larry elder was
moderating it and Larry's libertarian
liber and Larry was was asking you know
about seatbelt laws and everybody sort
of solemnly proclaimed that there should
be no seatbelt laws except for Gary
Johnson who said well maybe people
should have to have a license before
they drive now I'm actually sympathetic
to the arguments that see that Oro's a
driver's license question for the
driver's license laws are silly and they
this is what tort law is for if you hit
somebody then you get sued and that's
that's just the way that it works but
the the enthusiasm in the room for get
rid of driver's licenses seems not like
the smartest outward-facing pitch to the
American public I agree and I'm frankly
okay with driver's licenses because you
sue the person the reckless person he
doesn't have any money to pay he has no
disincentive to learn how to drive so we
need your threat when you're potentially
threatening a lot of other people it's
pretty amazing we allow I mean if they
would never be allowed today if some if
we were using horses still and someone
said I have a new form of transport
it'll it'll be less solid waste
pollution but more air pollution good
trade-off less stuff on the street that
needs cleaning and what we're gonna
drive them at 50 miles per hour inches
from pedestrians it would never be
approved today the seatbelt laws I think
are a more interesting interesting case
because that's your own body and studies
have shown that when people wear
seatbelts they drive faster that these
things have unintended consequences one
economist made the point that the
biggest car safety device would be a
bike coming off the steering cause you
drive horses but it's my body I should
decide whether it wear a seatbelt it's
interesting that you think that about
driver's licenses where do you draw the
line on occupational licensing so you've
talked about how there should be none
even for doctors and lawyers people
assume that if the government doesn't
protect us were unprotected but if it
weren't for that licensing consumer
groups
underwriters laboratories consumer
reports somebody would set up a private
testing operation they would rate
doctors and lawyers and you wouldn't
just pick one you would go check the
guide and you'd know something maybe
this guy gets a B but he's cheaper and
that's my choice but now you just assume
the government is doing it usually
they're sleeping and they aren't and
we're less safe
so why do you think the Liberty a what
can be done are you a libertarian party
voter first of all do you how do you
vote I generally vote libertarian party
I'll vote for Larry sharp this year in
New York he's unusually sharp
libertarian so yellows voters are stupid
I mean again is it is it possible that
it's it's just a lack of internal
cohesion among libertarians I mean it's
it's it's always hard to group
individuals and anytime you try to get
people into into one box people tend to
climb out particularly if they're
libertarian what let's say you were
running a libertarian party you want to
fix this because it was it was a source
of great frustration to me during the
last election cycle I was looking at
both of these candidates and going
you've got to be kidding me and then I
looked at a libertarian party and I've
got Gary Johnson over there flubbing
aleppo and I mean it can anything be
done to save the Libertarian Party or is
it basically just a giant scam for the
leadership to make a certain amount of
money no it's not a scam they are they
are dedicated people who believe in this
stuff and are trying but it's tough it's
a two-party country people we pay
attention the people listening and
watching now pay attention it said 1% of
the people make things happen
9% watch to make things happen then
that's your audience in my audience and
90% of the people wake up the next day
and say
what happened I think it's true because
people are thinking about their families
and their religion and movies and music
and making money and their friends and
sports and they're not paying attention
to politics suddenly they're asked to
vote and half those people then do vote
they vote who it's Republican or
Democrat they don't pay attention long
enough to hear the libertarian argument
says the better move to try and take
over the Republican Party from within as
opposed to try and running a libertarian
party from without you think maybe I
when I first woke up I thought the the
democrats would be more willing to
embrace these ideas because you
religious conservatives it's moral you
can't argue with that
and i went to a father of one of the
kids that my kids school had a radio
show said is a smart guy went to harvard
i can convince him on this radio show
about the folly of the welfare state i
got the facts and that was l frank and
he ended up screaming at me and i'm
could never make a date a dent with the
left Peter Piot the anchorman in the
hallway at ABC would turn away when he
saw me because after years of being a
liberal basher business I was now
defending capitalism and criticizing
government suddenly I was no longer
objective and I was never won another
Emmy Award and they were angry people
were somebody came up to me in the
street in New York and said you John
Stossel I hope you die soon wow this
just and the anger was from the left
that I was a consumer reporter
criticizing government protecting people
what I'm seeing is a big libertarian
move at least philosophically if not
politically openly among young people
because there's basically a consensus
that's been reached on social issues
other than abortion in which people
basically say go to it you want nobody
cares leave us alone and that that has
extended to drugs and trying to ask you
about in a second drug legalization the
do you think that there's hope with with
young people because they'll leave me
alone theme seems to be picking up some
ground I mean it's the theme that I
spend an awful lot of time pushing
myself whenever I go to college campuses
stay out of my business I'll stay out of
yours and you know you don't have to
worry about my religious institution
because I don't care about yours just do
what you want basically as long as it's
not hitting anybody else in the face I
think that's that's a resonant message
with a lot of young people but you know
getting bogged down in the details is
always a bit of a mistake do you do you
see a moving Liberty a kind of creeping
libertarianism that's that's rising up a
little bit
creeping yeah but that's not good enough
and far more are showing up at Bernie
rallies with their fantasies about
socialism well so let alone and move
into the drug area for a second so this
is obviously one of the areas of serious
contention and it's weird cuz it's
cross-cutting there are some people on
the right like me who are in favor of
marijuana decriminalization there are
some people who are still drug warriors
on the left you see a lot of folks are
still drug warriors and some people who
are in favor of legalization when should
drugs be decriminalized when should they
when should they remain criminal if ever
I think they should all be
decriminalized today and there can be
rules states can pick what the age of
majority is 16 18 21 but do we own our
own once you're an adult don't we own
our own bodies and you make the
marijuana point which is easier to right
Jess but I've come to think that if you
own your own body it's your choice and
the scare is about the worst of a little
crack are not accurate that there always
are going to be surges of good and bad
drugs legal and illegal they'll go up
people will see the harm from the bad
ones they'll go down the laws only make
it worse by driving it underground and
creating a criminal network it's too
powerful too rich so here's here's the
libertarian counter argument or a
quasi-libertarian counter argument with
regard to things like heroin so the the
this is an argument I first heard
articulated by Jonah Goldberg so the the
fundamental basis of libertarianism is
obviously the capacity of each human
being to reason and you do stuff for
Reason magazine it's the idea that we
all have the ability to think make
rational decisions and then live with
those rational decisions drugs at least
hard drugs like heroin robbed you of
that like if you're if you're on heroin
you're not thinking you're not capable
of
rational thought you're not capable of
making choices addiction has basically
taken over the rational centers of your
brain where are you supposed to go from
there do you think that there's a decent
counter-argument to the libertarian
position on this based on the idea that
once people have been robbed of their
individuality and capacity to function
as human beings by these drugs that
we've now moved out of the realm of it's
your body your choice well if you've
been robbed of your capacity for choice
yes but no because did prohibition work
well alcohol robbed can rob you of your
ability to make good choices and banning
it made things worse
are there gradations though I mean
alcohol you have to imbibe an awful lot
of alcohol to be robbed of your of your
choice and apparently there are plenty
of people who are heroin addicts in
Europe who go to work so it'd mean meth
is probably the worst but I would still
say in a free country it ought to be
your choice if you want to poison
yourself so let's talk a little bit
about the American Constitution so in my
view the American Constitution is the
single greatest piece of governmental
literature ever written it's it's a
brilliant way of attempting to balance
out some checks and balances I know
there's some libertarian skepticism
certain elements of the of the
Constitution how do you feel about the
the system that the founders put in
place do you think that it was stringent
enough in reducing the size and scope of
government is it that we've strayed from
the Constitution or is that the the
faults were built in that we now have
this gigantic massive overarching
government I think it was pretty good
except for the lack of pollution rules
and slavery but if you when I read what
they wrote they were vigilant about the
growth of government we have to guard
against this how can we guard against
this because it's the natural progress
of things at Jefferson for government to
grow and Liberty to yield and they wrote
it down but a piece of paper isn't
enough to stop this trend because
wherever there are rulers wherever there
are Donald Trump's people will want to
say yeah let's do this
I ought to be able to and and let's
make more happen and it's very hard to
fight that that's part of the thing that
I found so fascinating about some of the
the trumpian sentiments on the right so
you know I think the Trump is governed
much more conservatively than I thought
he would have you know based on the
priorities oh yeah correct but there
there are a lot of Trump fans who are in
some ways almost indistinguishable
philosophically from Bernie fans we had
on Tucker Carlson a couple of weeks ago
and and Tucker was extraordinarily
interventionist when it came to the
economy he was talking about how he
wanted he actually said outright that he
would ban self-driving cars for example
because it gets rid of trucking jobs
he's very much in favor of tariffs and
all the rest of what happened he used to
be so good on this yeah and and I wonder
if it's just human nature to - that
we're fighting against that in in
essence libertarians are basically
fighting against the natural Drive of
human beings to look for man-made
solutions to problems that cannot be
alleviated by man-made solutions is it
possible - to fight human nature and if
so what are these sort of well let's say
you're constructing an educational
system for a young person and I get this
a lot which books should people read
well what are the ideas they should
engage with so I'm you know you're
talking to a kid who's five years old or
their parents and you're trying to
educate them to become a free market
free minded individual what's the
literature you start them on how what's
that diet look like economics are one
easy lesson by Haslam Atlas Shrugged
it's a good guy give me a break buy me
Milton Friedman's free to choose well
but you know most young people won't
read books it's why I'm making videos
you mentioned Tucker I I just released a
video on Amazon Jeff Bezos and it was I
started it with a video defending base
Bezos against Bernie saying how dare
Bernie attacked this man who yes he's
the richest man in the world but he's
made us all richer by lowering prices so
much the Fed even lowered its inflation
rate and they pay vast amounts in taxes
and their investors pay lots of money in
taxes he's good for America
being trashed but I'm midway through
writing this piece and Bezos caves in to
the progressives and says yeah I'm gonna
raise all my workers to fifteen bucks an
hour cutting off performance bonuses
stupidly perhaps still it's his company
he can do that he'll find very good
workers for that but then he goes on and
says I'm gonna lobby like another craven
opportunist rather than a capitalist I'm
gonna Lobby government to force every
company to pay $15 to get rid of the
competitive advantage my competitors
would have and since I got lots of
robots for placing workers I'm gonna
really crush these guys if they have to
pay 15 bucks an hour capitalism's
biggest enemies are often capitalists
yeah and then this is I think a great
point that libertarians I wish would
make more often because the the kind of
pie in the sky Rosie view of free
markets is always the people are gonna
act morally within free markets but the
truth is they're a bunch of people as
long as the big government capacity out
there who are gonna take advantage of
that this is why when folks say well big
business is is capitalists like have you
been watching big business they hope
you're watching any business human
beings are willing to take advantage of
each other which is why you do need I
always yeah I keep coming back to this
and I think that this is the and not to
not to promote my own ideology but I'm
going to because my show that you do
need a tremendous focus on bringing up
virtuous people in a free system if the
free system is gonna last because
otherwise people are just going to try
and pervert
the system for their own ends which is
exactly what you're talking about with
Bezos and when people say crony
capitalism the sacrimoni capitalism
that's economic fascism it's exactly the
same sort of state-sponsored monopolize
'im that you were seeing in in early you
know posted by Maher Germany so it's
it's it's really I think it's necessary
for libertarians and I include myself in
this number to spend an awful lot of
time teaching people that that virtue is
necessary and that's why you know it's
the markets are great but this is where
this is what I think Adam Smith differs
from the the Lord Mandeville bees
metaphor right Adam Smith recognizes the
Lord says there's a very famous there
was a tract that was written right
before Adam Smith all about I forget the
name of the the tract by a
written by Mandeville and it was
basically the it's a piece of poetry
it's like 500 lines about the the
economy of the bees and his basic idea
is that economies develop because people
have vices private vices become public
virtues in other words you want to buy a
nice piece of jewelry and therefore this
creates economic growth because you want
something that you didn't have before
and maybe it's coming from selfishness
and greed right it's sort of an advice
so my wanting it would be the vice in
this particular in this particular
scenario but what Adam Smith says and
he's correct is that
well that's true with regard to vices
that are not inherently damaging to the
system they're vices that are inherently
damaging to the system and so we have to
teach people that freedom can only
preserve by people who actually spend an
awful lot of time thinking about virtue
Wow
that's bigger than I can I can't digest
or put into one of my five-minute videos
yeah well let's talk about for a second
the the changes there's hard for a Bezos
to resist he's almost not doing a duty
to his shareholders when there's this
monster government over here doling out
for you have put your headquarters here
I'll give you a tax break in some ways
he'd be a fool not to ask for it the
only solution is to shrink the state and
why did Japan and Germany do so well
after World War two because we bobbed
them to smithereens and they had to
start over and they got rid of all the
guilds and the special interests that
were holding progress back and then they
grew so fast
it's a horrible deplorable a depressing
idea to say that's the only way to stop
the growth of government but maybe it is
I'm not saying you keep asking me how do
we convince Raybould can we teach virtue
and I don't know that you can so let's
talk about foreign policy because this
is an area where there's wide
differentiation between sort of
conservatives and libertarians Rand Paul
made this most obvious in 2016 when he
was seen as sort of a an early
frontrunner for the nomination in 2016
and then he started focusing in sort of
his father's fashion on foreign policy
more than he was focusing on domestic
policy because when it comes to domestic
stuff we're on Rand Paul and probably
Ron Paul and I agree on 90% of things
and when it comes to foreign policy then
we have
of the ways so where are you on foreign
policy what do you think the role of the
US government is on the international
scene keep us safe and fights moral wars
on rare occasions and get out as quickly
as you can and don't nation bills and
don't have troops in the 70 countries we
have troops and now because we make more
enemies than we kill well what do you
make of the argument that basically we
are whether we like it or not this has
been thrust upon us that we are the the
most powerful country on the planet that
we have trade connections with States
all over the world that those foreign
markets in order for them to remain open
we actually do have to have a somewhat
stable international system and that the
externalities of of things around the
world have pretty significant impact on
America more so than then maybe we want
to acknowledge because there's just too
many situations in which something bad
happens and we say okay well how is that
possibly going to affect us and next
thing you know it is to take for example
the situation in Syria which really has
no impact on us except for the massive
migrant wave that is now swamped
governments in Europe and when I say
swamped I don't mean the Syrians are
coming in and voting people out I mean
reaction to that has actually toppled
governments in Europe and created all
sorts of new issues particularly with
regard to trade because a lot of the
parties who are standing against
immigration are also standing against
free trade you know what do you what do
you make of that argument that it's a we
don't have a choice basically well we we
ought to decide what the mission is and
make some choices and I don't presume to
know what we should do about Syria and a
lot of these hard cases and it's not my
area of specialty I try to stick to
economics but policing the ceilings
China wants to keep them open too
because if there isn't free flow of
traffic that hurts their people Europe
wants to keeping them keep them open so
does Brazil it doesn't need to be all up
to the United States and how would you
feel if you came home to your
neighborhood drug store and there are
foreign troops speaking a foreign
language wearing foreign uniforms in
your neighborhood and they have some
power
over your cousins and uncles I'd be
pissed off and I would hate America for
that and John Bolton the Fox as a friend
he I assume agrees with you and I would
argue with him on this the Ron Paul
argument what about blowback didn't we
when we drone and kill an alleged
terrorist in Afghanistan
don't we make enemies of all of his
cousins and little brothers and as
technology gets better soon they're
gonna put some atomic bomb and something
this small it'll be easier to kill us
with isn't it better if we don't make as
many enemies and Bolton brilliantly
would answer with things like well when
I was sitting with Nixon and well when I
was in the cave and this place and I
would just get lost in the fascinating
story in several shows and one long
dinner I don't think I ever got a good
answer I mean I still think the best
answer to that is a lot of these folks
want to kill us anyway I mean that you
drone a terrorist you know there's a
decent shot that that terrorist was was
interested in killing you and his
friends were interested in killing you
in the first place and again I'm not an
interventionist in a lot of these areas
I was against the war in Libya for
example but it's but by the same token
it is interested enough to come here and
do it I don't think so well I mean but
that wasn't that what 9/11 was just
certain extent because we weren't
involved in Afghanistan before 9/11 and
and they weren't from Afghanistan they
were Saudis who were mad that American
troops were all over the Middle East
that was directed from Afghanistan
obviously I mean it was bin Laden in
Afghanistan being housed by the Taliban
right and that justified our going in
there to take out bin Laden than the
people who directly assaulted us but I
think they wanted to kill us
because we have troops in the Middle
East so do you think that the best
approach with with countries like China
for example which is seen by a lot of
folks as a real foreign policy threat is
open trade do you think that economics
converts these countries to you know
better ways of life or it's just who
cares we may as well afraid with them no
I think it might open them up to a
smarter way of life it said if goods
cross borders armies Dalton you
want to kill people who you trade with
and in general it improves things I
don't think it'll work miracles they
still may want to crush us in some other
way but unilateral trade disarmament and
I think Trump is very wrong in his
tariffs would benefit them and us well I
think that the so the counter-argument
on there and that would be that the kind
of McDonald's theory of foreign policy
which is you know the Golden Arches
theory that countries that have
McDonald's don't have wars with us that
in the in lead-up to World War one there
actually was significantly increased
world trade including with Germany and
within Europe and then World War one
broke out an ideology still has a
tremendous role to play in human action
and and that human beings are not
necessarily driven purely by economic
concerns and this is that I think this
links up with a with a broader critique
of libertarianism that I've heard from
folks in sort of mainstream conservative
circles which is libertarianism is
relying on a view of human nature that
is not inherently conservative it's
we are essentially materialists well
malleable and materialist so that not
only are we malleable in terms of our
nature that you know systems will make
us better
but also we are malla but also we are
materialist in that if we experience
better economic times then this makes us
less likely to do bad things and that's
actually kind of fundamentally non
conservative in a certain way right
because the the linkage between poverty
and crime is to my mind less significant
than the linkage between values in crime
and the same thing would hold true on
foreign policy you can have rich
countries that are pursuing tremendous
evil against their own citizens and you
can have poor countries well you can't
have poor it let's put this way you
can't have poor countries pursuing
tremendous good for their citizens that
doesn't really work but you can't have
rich countries to pursue tremendous evil
obviously yeah I I don't claim that
trade is going to solve that making
people richer will solve these problems
revolutions the poor are more likely to
rise up when their incomes are going up
than when their suffering and misery
libertarianism doesn't claim to have the
answer to all these problems but it does
say our basic freedom is important and
we ought to be left alone and part of
that is freedom to trade with Pete
and generally that brings good things
okay so solve all these prophets talked
about trade for a second this is
obviously become deeply controversial
I'm a free trader the only time I ever
think that that trade should be curbed
our would be for actual national
security reasons you're at war with
somebody or something but there are a
lot of folks who have been focusing in
recently on the idea that the downsides
of trades outweigh the the upside of
trade and they look at downs or Oren
caste has it has a new book out that is
kind of along these lines and I was
fascinated by it he has a chapters book
what he basically says that we've missed
the boat in in the Western world in
thinking that material prosperity is the
goal of the economy without a certain
amount of job involvement or employment
material prosperity doesn't solve the
problem what he means by that is he
suggests that there are two main models
that are now being pursued by people who
are not libertarian model number one is
there are a bunch of rich people there a
bunch of poor people who are being left
behind because of advances in the
economy as we move to an IQ based
economy as opposed to a back-breaking
labor based economy and that means those
people are gonna get left behind what
happens to all of those people okay well
we let the economy spring ahead but we
redistribute some well from here there
and that sort of placates everybody
that's theory number one theory number
two is that we actually put in place
regulations to prevent the economy from
springing ahead far enough so that those
people are left behind so what's your
view on what we do with folks if the
singularity is coming if we're moving
toward a more service and intellect
based economy what do we do with all the
folks who could be out of a job in 10
years as automation takes over for them
we've had more trade than ever up to
trump and unemployment is at a
remarkably low number people worried
when 90% of the people worked on the
farms
what are they get what are all those
people gonna do what are all the
secretary is going to do if they lose
their jobs or their telephone
switchboard operators they all lost
their jobs and more people got employed
human ingenuity is such the beauty of
the human brain to find new things to
serve people now a lot of smart
artificial intelligence people say this
time it's different
and this time they're all we need a
guaranteed basic income which I think
would be a terrible thing because we get
purpose and work but I mean until that
happens to try to manipulate the economy
to prevent growth I just think it's
cruel okay so let's talk for a second
about the technology companies so you
mentioned earlier Amazon there's been a
lot of talk in right-wing circles
recently and left-wing circles always
because there's always talking about
winged circles about regulation they
talk more about about regulating
companies like Google and Facebook these
kind of massive companies that have all
sorts of information on us that we
voluntarily given them but now they have
you know in in the view of some sort of
a monopoly on this what do you make of
the argument in favor of regulation of
companies like Google or Facebook and
their manipulation of informational
access bad idea because whoever does the
regulation will make things worse and we
voluntarily gave them that information
they have it they sell it people steal
it
except for identity theft so what I've
lost my privacy I already have enough
enemies in New York as a man from the
left who's moved to libertarian that I
figure there's some 18 year old kid in
the apartment next door who's stealing
my emails anyway we the idea that the
government is gonna make that better is
terrifying also if it gets really bad if
Google starts doing horrible stuff and
look I tried when they fired
James two more for saying something
reasonable about gender differences I
said screw them I'm gonna go to Bing and
I'm not gonna use I'm gonna be a
consumer reacting you I couldn't even do
it so they're too big but government has
no way to make it better and if they
gets horrible government does have the
guns and in the end government could
always step in okay so one of the other
areas where folks talk about kind of
global regulation you mentioned in the
context of the environment is in the
area of global warming so people are
deeply concerned over the the climate
changing it seems that the vast majority
of scientists agree that the climate is
growing warmer to what extent we still
don't know and the vast majority also
agree that whatever warming has occurred
over the past century or so is at least
majority attributable to human activity
how worried are you about global warming
what role does government have in
regulating environmental emissions for
example in this particular area because
libertarians have basically been called
skeptics and clemont's and irons because
of their because of their hands-off
approach where are you on this well I
don't see how you can deny a climate
because we have climate and climate
changes and it is getting warmer has
been getting warmer
I don't agree that it's so clear that
man does most of it certainly man does
some of it but I don't think there's
necessarily agreement on that but the
next two steps are the important ones
will it be a disaster and can we do
anything about it so the disaster
partment we have disasters we have a
million people dying of malaria and
dysentery in the world we have problems
where economic growth would really help
and stifling that in the name of this
possible problem and there are smart
people who say it may be good you'll
grow more stuff in Canada there's there
are fewer deaths and heat waves than in
cold waves we can adjust we can pull
back from the oceans if it keeps warming
there may be natural things more warm
water means more evaporation it means
more clouds and maybe this will stop
naturally we don't really know how big a
crisis it is but certainly it's no
crisis is big enough to waste money
doing nothing and that's what the
billions of dollars were spending now is
doing nothing it's that the earth won't
notice it's arrogant for man to think
that by buying a Prius or driving or
outside your that's gonna make any
difference I mean even if China and
India weren't continuing to build coal
plants with the technology we have now
it's not going to help but if we don't
bankrupt ourselves on stupid mandates
for wind power and nonsense like that in
10 years we'll be much richer and then
if we know more about the problem then
maybe we can
do something about it okay so John I do
have one final question before I want to
ask you why you don't just run for
president I'm a libertarian ticket but
if you actually like to hear the answer
you're gonna have to subscribe to
subscribe all you have to do is head
over to Daley wire.com slash subscribe
and then you'll be able to hear the end
of our conversation there so John
Stossel thanks so much for coming in
really appreciate it go check your stuff
out at Stossel TV we have a new video
coming out every week or I have a free
week yes
libertarian videos short enough not to
be boring
appreciate it thanks so much for
stopping by thank you the Ben Shapiro
shows Sunday special is produced by
Jonathan hey executive producer Jeremy
borin associate producer Mathis Glover
edited by Alex Singaram audio is mixed
by Dylan case hair and makeup is by Jess
wah all Vera and title graphics by
Cynthia and hula Ben Shapiro shows
Sunday special is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018
[Music]